sanaa ap qu'un magasin de cd de dvd il a
invité au club st voilà elle a son petit
magasin de cd d'un dvd ya un mec qui
rentre il lui dit excusez moi est-ce que
vous avez des films pornos et lui dit
oui on a des films pornos pour vos
portes et nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est qui ça allô allô oui oui bonjour
oui je sais ça ne mérite bien vu qu'elle
te dire que tu en penses
ces arrêts habitants
[Applaudissements]
mon bébé a juste village écoulé 17 et un
bouddha tew série blake le suit dans le
sud de la france paraît tous ensemble
raconte des blagues dans le sud hôte est
moche et on espère qu'il viendra bientôt
sur platon cyr et je sais que tu vois on
t'attend tous et on t'aime sport et
break tu veux nous raconter un petit un
petit buy way they les loups les loups
ils arrivent avec des parents dans les
années 60 il arrive de tunis et paris
allaient très bien chanter mais les
loups hilali dont il parle pas du métal
sous les sons pertes et par mois là on
arrive en france mêlant la louche pour
que tu parles les substituts il pleure
et vous bref ils l'emmènent vide écoute
les loups maintenant on est en france il
faut absolument je vais t'emmener chez
les bonnes soeurs
il emmène chez les bonnes soeurs là-bas
dans une campagne il tape à la porte
un succès par ippon préférence il ya une
bonne sortie d'hugo laporte il est
diplomate à olaya monfils la louche peut
vous laisser pendant six mois a ainsi
bouclé il aimerait vraiment je suis sûr
que ça va lui plaire
et quand je reviens donc voilà je suis
sûr qu'avec vous il va apprendre le
français mais bien sûr monsieur avec
plaisir à l'est entre la logique ont
prié en la lui rend à six mois après son
père ils arrivent ils tapent à la porte
il vient rechercher troupe pif il est
très heureux comme pas partir trop pour
la même bonne soeur bonjour madame dit
mais tu me rappelle très bien de vous
vous êtes le papa de la nourriture et
bien sûr et les pas la bonne placer au
tombeau à plélo la halle aux hôtes avec
des samoa
au rayon des arrivées mais toi tu as
compris la blague mais je suis un vrai
bilan de ces matches est fort mon frérot
merci d'abord être avec toi t'as du
boulot c'est un arabe
oui on change pas c'est un arabe en fait
qui qui a un problème avec ses dents
fait hyper hyper ses dents et il lui
reste que dedans donc il va chez le
dentiste est déjà un problème chez
permet dans les métiers où il faut me
mettre des dents mais témoin des dents
et d'anti simili bac il dit bart nous on
a les incisives
c'est 10 euros les canines ses 50 euros
et les molaires ses 100 euros l'arabie
l'organe du frérot mais moi des
incisives partout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]